[Music]
look what I become
episode 252 Our Guest today Lieutenant
Colonel West over 21 years of service in
the U.S army still I think you're doing
some active reserve right now no no I'm
I'm completely clear on that yeah I'm
done done and uh also you lived here I
mean we're talking about I met you we're
in Dallas we're at the Providence Towers
in Dallas if you know the one on uh at
Jersey Mike's out with me yeah you would
go to that Jersey Mike's I'm like wait a
minute it's Em Right and I think we you
met him one time at a bank we had a
conversation with Spring Valley and
North Dallas but it's great to have you
we got a lot of topics to go through
folks so uh obviously there's a footage
that came out from the Nashville
shooting we'll look at that and you know
comment on uh what these guys did the
the the the police officers how quickly
they moved on that and how other states
can learn from this the experience of
different places will get your thoughts
on that there's some commentary of what
uh Randy Weingarten calls for gun
confiscation we must have the courage to
do what Australia and New Zealand and
other places did and I'd be curious if
you're open to the idea of allowing your
guns to be confident no Nikki Haley said
treating shootings as only a gun issue
is the lazy way out after Nashville
school tragedy there's some things going
on right now where the poll that came
out showing Biden tops Trump by two
points
Ron DeSantis was asked in an interview
if he'd be willing to be Trump's vice
president his answer is telling we'll
talk about that Christy said GOP needs
someone who can quickly take down Trump
and I think he had a chance to do that
last time but his strategy wasn't
effective maybe it's changing this time
FTX founder Sam bankman freed charged
with bribing Chinese officials there's a
clash very surprising Bernie Sanders
clashing with a man who produced 402 000
jobs worldwide uh the Seal of Howard of
Starbucks there's a back and forth you
have to see this clip we'll have it
we'll show it to you U.S surpasses
Russia as Europe's top supply of crude
oil there's some things going on right
now between China France last night all
night I'm not even kidding with you I'm
getting text messages from different
people I'm communication with is this
deal with oil of China Russia Saudi Iran
a real thing is this really going to be
happening for them to go away from the
U.S dollar and if that's the case why is
it that was a topic of discussion
literally all night through uh this
morning dumb phones are back at it again
a lot of people have smartphones parents
are now turned on by dumb phones you'll
see what dumb phones are Tom's got some
stuff to say about that a CEO shares
five toxic personality types he sees
over and over again you've dealt with a
lot of people in your life as a leader
maybe you have some things you can teach
us about leadership from different
personalities you work with and then
Obama's got some credit he gives to
Trump for a fantastic job he did uh
leading China obviously I'm being
sarcastic Obama blames Trump for
emboldened China and there's a couple
stories of New York Times one thing's
for sure if New York Times writes good
things about you don't get too excited
it's just a matter of time before they
turn you like they just did on faucy so
we'll cover that as well but having said
that uh Lieutenant Colonel Allen was for
the audience that doesn't know you if
you don't mind taking a couple minutes
and just give them your background
because you weren't just military can
Congress here in Florida in Dallas
you've been all over shared a little bit
of your background with your audience
well sure I was born and raised in
Atlanta Georgia uh you know I'm 62 years
of age in 1961 I was born a blacks only
hospital and think about how great this
country is that a guy can be born in a
Black's only hospital to be sitting here
with you all today grow up and become a
lieutenant colonel United States Army
Commander Battalion in combat when his
dad was just a Corporal in World War II
and his older brother was a lance
corporal Marine in Vietnam I served 22
years active duty service United States
Army retired in 2004 uh when you retire
you do what your wife asks and she's a
brilliant woman NBA and PhD so she got a
great offer with Raymond James and so we
came to South Florida in 2004 lived in
Plantation Fountain Springs Sunrise and
Nob Hill uh I taught high school at
Deerfield Beach for one year down here
and Coach track that was so exciting and
enjoyable that I volunteered to go back
to Afghanistan because I figured if
you're going to be in a combat zone you
need to be on uh so uh while I was in uh
doing that tour over there I someone
talked to me about running for congress
when my assignment finished in
Afghanistan mentoring the Afghan Army
and I ran for congress down here and was
elected in 2010 and served this district
from Fort Lauderdale uh airport all the
way up to Jupiter Inlet came out of
Congress and then got an offer to go
back to Texas where my last Duty
assignment Fort Hood was and so we went
back to Texas 2014 lived right outside
of Dallas I've been honored to be the
chairman of the Republican party of
Texas and just ran for governor of Texas
last year and now I'm here with you
Patrick and enjoying being back down
here in South Florida well first of all
thank you for your service my pleasure
to do what you do it's not something
that's easy to do especially those men
that many years and make it to the ranks
that you've made but uh so while you
were in your wife became a doctor so was
she getting all her education while you
guys served together how I was well it's
pretty interesting uh we we kind of met
while she was finishing up her MBA at
Long Island University she had
originally graduated from Kansas State
University and I was stationed out of
Fort Riley Kansas and so we were
introduced and Uh I that was my best
marketing routine ever to get a woman
that was a consultant on Wall Street uh
to to marry a dumb little you know
paratrooper captain at the time and move
back down to Kansas and she went from
Manhattan New York to Manhattan Kansas
the little apple that stuff but she
enjoyed it and so uh she got her PhD
there she was the first uh black
professor in the College of Business in
Kansas State University marketing and
finance and we had both of our daughters
out there who are now 29 and 26 uh our
oldest daughter graduated from Nova
South Eastern University right here yeah
right here NCAA division two Champions
the youngest graduate from FIU so uh
yeah respect yeah absolutely a couple
things one do you still identify as a
black man it wasn't that hilarious do
you still identify yourself as I want to
know if it's changed yeah you know that
that video you know more people see me
in airports or whatever say you're that
guy and I'm like what are you talking
about you you identified as black yeah I
kind of have to let me finish the
question yeah wait wait wait young lady
young you can tell immediately to Father
mode it was it was great scene it's
amazing this is Northwestern University
pretty highly intellectual uh have you
seen this no I have not oh my God can
you find me one here's explaining it
he'll look for it go ahead I'm a speaker
with Young Americans foundation so I go
on college campuses and the subject was
the Iranian nuclear agreement I love
foreign policy national security policy
and so I I figured I did pretty good I
nailed this thing and so they opened up
a question to ask a young lady comes up
to me first question she asked do you
identify as black I was just dumbfounded
I'm like where does I'm I mean we're
talking about nuclear agreements with
Iran and I said yeah but the the sad
thing is that we have people in America
and and even in the black community they
think that your skin color dictates how
you think and and that's one of the big
problems that I believe we have we have
gone backwards in race relations here in
the United States of America and this
cultural Marxism that we have been you
know permeated in our college and
university campus is now they're trying
to push it down to the K level uh we've
got to combat this I think that's the
number one issue that we have in the
United States you know a lot of people
will say uh uh uh what's going what's
trending right now is did you find it
that's the one the 27 second one if you
just want to click on that and and yeah
I think we you don't have Tick Tock okay
got it if you if you if you do the
following it just play this one it's
fine even though Rob
do you identify as black
no it's a serious question because you
might not identify can you please put
the mic thank you okay
with my questions
young lady I'm just asking you to listen
to me and I'm about to answer the first
question but I didn't I didn't finish my
question
okay
yeah I'm black
yeah
what do you think she was so angry about
that she wouldn't even let you answer
the question I mean well for those of us
that are not watching on YouTube and
just watching Spotify you are a black
man I can say that you know
download permanent tan yeah exactly yeah
grade 10. well yeah it is I've been
working on it for 62 years uh I think
the problem is that you know you've got
professors
telling these young kids that skin color
is supposed to identify people this is
the identity policy identity this is the
cultural Marxism that is out there and
the fear that these young people have is
that they don't want you to respond
because they are really afraid of you
totally embarrassing them with facts and
with knowledge and the other thing that
it shows is a lack of respect for elders
you know I've spoke at the University of
Buffalo I had to be escorted off the
campus of the University of Buffalo
because black students threatened to
hurt me now you know they probably would
have gotten a can of whoop ass open up
on them because I still have some skills
you know like Liam Neeson but the thing
is that here you had black students that
did not want to listen to what I think
is a decently accomplished you know
member of the black community because I
did not agree with their line that
America is a racist country and by the
way I think it's important to point out
for those of us that are just watching
not uh just on Spotify what have you she
was a black female it wasn't like she
was some white girl that was all getting
nuts over there how would you define uh
woke if you were to Define what woke
means what what does woke mean to you
woke means living in a delusion and and
a reverse reality of there's no
objective truth
that is it's all moral relativism is is
whatever situational ethics what have
you that works towards a certain end uh
and and I think that that's what we see
happening because none of this makes any
sense to stand up there and ask a person
do you identify as black first of all
what does Sam Hill does that mean and
and to to take the type of stance that
she took you know I remember when I was
a kid and I was sitting in the backseat
of the car and I had two aunts on either
side and they were talking to each other
and I interrupted them I got jab slapped
really quick I mean you know it was just
just how it happened with the backhand
and because I understood respect of our
elders we don't have respect of our
elders anymore and that's one of the
things that I saw when I was teaching
High School Deerfield Beach
every single day you're breaking up
fights you know why no one respects you
know that authority figure anymore and
so that's what I think this whole
wokeness does it breaks down the fabric
of of our culture and most importantly
the traditional nuclear family structure
you said race relations have gotten
worse in this country were and you said
you were born in a blacks only Hospital
in 1961 in Atlanta Georgia Atlanta
Georgia when did it when was it at its
peak worse and when was at its best you
know where have you seen it kind of uh
navigate over the last decade or two
well I I will be very honest I think
that the administration of Barack Obama
took uh race relations going in a
different direction uh when you have him
you know saying that the Cambridge
Police acted stupidly when you have Eric
Holder saying some of the things that he
said and here are here's the the quote
unquote first black president here's the
black attorney general and all of these
Great accomplishments but yet they
continue to say you know this is not
good enough you know and and you know to
now come up with this you know cultural
I mean this uh CRT and everything it
says that I'm sitting here next to Tom
and I'm looking over here at Adam you
guys are oppressors
how can that be and I'm I'm supposed to
be oppressed you know so we are going
backwards and we have taken Marxism
which was a socio-economic divisive uh
platform and we've taken it over to to
race uh and I will tell you that when I
grew up in my neighborhood the old
Fourth Ward neighborhood in Atlanta
Georgia that's where Dr Martin Luther
King Jr was born and raised Ebenezer
churches Baptist Church is there I saw
businesses I saw doctors offices lawyers
offices Auburn Avenue I I first uh the
black owned bank Citizens Trust Bank but
now when you go into our inner cities
what do you see
you see something completely different
you see the lack of small business
entrepreneurship and growth you see the
breakdown of the traditional nuclear
family when I was born the traditional
nuclear family and the black community
was 75 to 77 percent today is 24 and and
how did that happen when did this
dissent start Lyndon Johnson Great
Society programs you know war on poverty
which created poverty it created
dependency which is a tenet of socialism
creating the welfare Nanny State
economic dependency and all this type of
stuff by way of wealth redistribution
and so that's where I think it really
started to go in a different direction
with these this you know Great Society
programs and and look at what we have
happening look at look at the gang
violence and everything in these inner
city communities and that's all across
the United States of America so that's
what I think we have this dissent and we
really kicked it into overdrive coming
out of the Obama administration because
the progressive socialist left can only
Advance Itself by means of dividing us
and they have gone back to racial
division
how do we where do we go from here that
we can actually improve this because if
you look at all the polling of gen Z you
know baby boomers when you talk about
patriotism in this country and being
proud to be American baby boomers are at
70 something percent then you have Gen X
right uh at I think 50 Millennials 40
and then gen Z 16 proud to be American
yeah and you see the status that we
discussed yesterday from The Wall Street
Journal about having children and work
and work ethic and patriotism and the
numbers are plummeting and you know a
lot of large contingency of our audience
are 20 and 30 year olds in this
Millennial gen Z generation how do we
improve upon this and get this back of
get patriotism back to being uh
exactly right there Mainstay in America
right there 16 of gen Z are proud to be
Americans Where Do We Go From Here well
it's very simple adults have to be
adults again
uh my mom and daddy were the adults in
the house and when my dad sat me down at
the age of 15 on the steps of his home
661 Kennesaw Avenue Northeast Atlanta
Georgia 30308
404-874-2836 he told me at the age of 15
that there's no greater honor than to
wear the uniform in the United States of
America now this is a man that was born
in the south in 1920.
and that's what he felt this was a man
that went and fought for his country in
World War II when this country did not
recognize him as being equal to others
but that's what he told me he challenged
me to be the first officer in the family
because he said I want you to be better
and more than what I was how old were
you at the time 15 and so what did I
start off with I started out in High
School Junior ROTC Grady High School
Atlanta Georgia and then I went on to
University of Tennessee on 31 July 1982
the only time I ever saw my dad with
tears in his eyes the day that he penned
on second Lieutenant bars it's amazing
but see that's what is not happening it
was not happening is that parents are
not taking charge in their homes parents
are Outsourcing their kids to these
teachers and and everyone else until the
culture as well my parents were it they
were the end State I did not come home
from the University of Tennessee for
Thanksgiving Christmas or any type of
break and say my professor is smarter
than you if that had been the case I
wouldn't be sitting here
so what happened when all of a sudden
you know Proverbs 22 6 says train up a
child the way they should go so when
they grow old they shut up depart from
it when did we all of a sudden in our
homes say we're not going to raise our
kids because that's what the left
believes
your kids are not yours when Terry
McAuliffe stood there on that debate
stage in Virginia doing the
gubernatorial election that said parents
do not have a right in what their
children are being taught
that's what they believe that's what
they have been saying in their own
little private meetings now what is it
well we're going to tell your kid that
if it's a little boy maybe he's a little
girl and we're not going to let you know
parents you were talking about earlier
how in the military I said sir to you
and you said yeah what things are
changing right now totally how so what
is it like today to be in America if you
were in the Army today can I call you
sir today no we're in today no they're
they're they're you know pushing against
that uh when you have the Secretary of
Defense Lloyd Austin who was a retired
four-star general black man by the way
and I served with him at Fort Bragg when
he was he was a colonel and and he had a
brigade in the 82nd Airborne Division
everyone looked up to him
but I don't know who this guy is now
when you are the Secretary of Defense
and you're writing a letter uh to the to
the force that says female troops have
to be prepared to be in shower and
bathroom facilities with biological
males did he wrote a letter he wrote a
memo you can you can find it you can he
wrote a memo on that Robert can you find
this memo that's that he wrote Austin
Secretary of Defense the amendment that
he sent out and you know the the United
States Marines there was a study that
was done I think the University of
Pennsylvania saying that you know you
should move away from calling people sir
a ma'am because that's affirming their
gender and maybe they want to have their
gender affirmed so just call them by
their Rank and their last name don't
call them about it first name you know
it this this is the type of stuff that's
happening in our military now when you
knew this guy was he a heavyweight tough
guy strong leader was he his call sign
was Panther six I mean he is the
original black panther okay that's how
we saw him so what happened to him so
what happened what happened show an
image of him by the way so people can
get a good look at what what what
happens is that
your last promotion in the military as
an officer Congress you need to well no
the last promotion is Brigadier general
or one star that's my little general
that's a one-star yeah that's that's
when you're uh uh you know your peers
two star three star four stars all
political points and so what you end up
finding out is guys who want to continue
on at that that level
end up surrendering to the political
whims and and the administration of the
time
and that's what the problem is and and
so Barack Obama comes along and all of
these generals they were there he says
you either get along with my agenda or
you're gone and that was a big thing
that people were writing about the
purging of senior level leadership in
the military during the Barack Obama
administration and so all of a sudden
you get these type of generals and if
there's one thing that Donald Trump did
not understand
he had to clean house
he had to clean house and every single
uh government agency you know not just
cabinet position but five six maybe
seven tiers down
and he did not get that and so that's
why you have these people like a general
Millie he's still hanging around and
some of the things he's doing I mean a
United States General saying you know
before a a hearing in Congress that you
know I want to study and understand what
white rage is
you know what you're supposed to be
doing is making sure that we can deploy
we can fight we can win that's it none
of this you know cultural Marxism and
and meanwhile if you're the enemy with
with seeing uh today XI and Putin coming
together saying the next hundred years
is going to be epic I'm paraphrasing but
they use the certain words saying what
the next hundred years are going to be
how do you think the enemy if we look at
some of our enemy let's say Iran let's
say China let's say Russia how do they
view America when they see the military
getting this off we're weak and and this
is the wind of opportunity that they
they have sat around and waited for
that's why the world is more
Machiavellian than ever before everyone
sees this is the opportunity where I can
rise up so when you see what happened in
Afghanistan that's a green light and
think about this uh there would not be
this conflagration in Ukraine if there
had not been in Afghanistan China would
not be threatened in Taiwan if they had
not seen what's happened in Afghanistan
when you leave 80 something billion
dollars of military equipment over there
and I spent two and a half years in
Afghanistan this is U.S military
equipment that you left yes they're
going to figure out a way to back
engineer that and they're going to make
it operational and that's exactly what
they see happening so they see weakness
and China has the one belt one road
strategy which talks about their
hegemonic dominance and you guys are
sitting here in South Florida okay guess
what not too far away here in the
Bahamas China's building Port facilities
in the Bahamas yes my wife is Jamaican
okay you go down to the the new cruise
port facility in in Jamaica it was built
by the Chinese they're all over the
place they're in our hemisphere because
they see this as a time and China
understands that we did not defeat the
Soviet Union militarily
we defeated the Soviet Union
economically
and so when we all of a sudden believe
that we're going to allow China to come
into you know most favorite trade Nation
status bring them into the world
economic uh Community they saw that as a
window of opportunity to less become the
tick that implants ourselves into
Western Civilization let's you know send
them all the cheap goods and everything
like that you know once upon a time we
had a problem with Chinese drywall right
here in South Florida killing people
they're they're killing us the fentanyl
this is a chemical war that we're in you
know being aided embedded by the the
drug cartels who are terrorist
organization so yes Russia China Iran
North Korea Islamic jihadism they all
see this as an opportunity I know that
you want to talk about the oil and gas
issue that's another issue that they see
that they can rise above us why would we
destroy our own energy Independence
why would we want to make ourselves
subservient once again to the OPEC plus
Nations and so instead of using our oil
and gas that we have here in abundance
to export that not only for our own
independence but to export that and to
undermine the revenues and resources
that these guys have now we have cut
ourselves off of the kneecap and they
see okay well let's uh let's jump in
here as well and now we're going and
begging the Saudis and so uh no by the
way who was down you know broken an
agreement between the Saudi arabias and
uh and Iran Xi Jinping yeah exactly I
want to read that to you though I want
to read a couple of these stories too
because you you've said a lot of things
here so here's the first one China
completes first one settled LNG trade uh
March 28th this is a Reuters story uh
and this is with France this is what a
lot of people were writing about and
talking about yesterday so Chinese
National oil company uh uh uh
Corporation and France's total energies
have completed China's first one settled
LNG trade through the Shanghai petroleum
and national gas exchange The Exchange
said on Tuesday approximately 65 000
tons of LNG imported from the UAE
changed hands in the trade China has
placed an emphasis on settling oil and
gas trades in one in recent years in a
bit to establish the currency
internationally and to weaken the
Dollar's grip on World Trade Russia has
increased increasingly embrace the Juan
Amid
Amid Western uh sanctions during a visit
to the Saudi Capital Riyadh in uh
December president Xi Jinping announced
that China would make full use of the
Shanghai exchange as a platform to carry
out one settlement of oil and gas trades
uh how bad can this be if they're able
to accomplish this and this becomes a
reality I mean obviously you're seeing
again China
Russia Saudi Iran Saudi and Iran is like
saying Red Sox and Yankees having dinner
together and doing business together
that's like saying hey you know Lakers
and Celtics at the Prime on how pique
it's like you guys are willing to get
together and do business together yet at
what cost anything to go up to see what
America is doing right now China is
winning these guys over the enemy of my
enemy is my friend well no question
about it so but but why why is it that
something like this isn't unifying
American reason why I want to ask this
from you is 911 unified us in a way we
kind of like listen I don't care who you
voted for man that's the enemy yeah okay
and you're red white and blue you're red
white and blue I don't care who you
voted for we're on the same team let's
roll okay covid was more political
because Trump was hated so much was like
no no China cannot be the enemy Trump
has to be enemy because we got to get
rid of this guy we had a shot at unified
during covet to have Dems Republicans
conservative Libertarians forget about
it Americans against China that's the
enemy there was a hesitation to make an
outside influence the enemy it was
easier to have somebody like Trump
because they didn't want him to do
whatever he was working on do you think
this could be something that unifies us
or no this is still going to be
something that's going to stay divided
it could be something that unifies us
but it's not going to happen out of the
white house because they're not going to
talk about this I mean the White House
the enemy of the progressive social is
left is anyone that poses their
ideological agenda
you know think about this how
interesting it was that during the
uprising of the protests in Hong Kong
you had those students there in Hong
Kong carrying American flags and singing
the National Anthem you can't get kids
on our College camps to carry American
flags and sing in the national anthem
because we don't talk about Liberty we
don't talk about Freedom we don't talk
about totalitarianism and the purveyors
thereof and we we don't have even a
president that talks about China is
killing and murdering you know Americans
18 to 14. what's the number one killer
of Americans 18 to 14 right now I mean
18 to 45 I'm sorry 18 it's fentanyl but
we don't have a president that talks
about it we don't have a president that
goes down and says that you know the
drug cartels are you know they're a
terrorist organizations that's pushing
human and sex trafficking that that
should unite us human and sex
trafficking uh the drug trafficking but
that's not the enemy that's not the
issue because what they want is complete
total
control of America so so so this is this
is what becomes a concern I sat down
with General McChrystal I think five
years ago six years ago and he's a four
star and he's good friends with Obama
and he is a Democrat he's on the left
and I think his father was a two star
uncles all this stuff were like one
stars or Colonels and all these things
and then you'll learn you're like okay
how do you become a two-star there's a
difference between a two-star and a one
star two star you need to you know but
one start you can kind of do your own
whatever you need to do to get there but
two three four star I need these guys to
like me to kind of say yes you're proof
to get this
so to me the compensation structure is
almost structured in a way
where
you have to compromise your values to
get the next level promotion
if that makes any sense it does so it's
set up in a way where I have to be
willing to compromise what I love most
about this country and what I
protected all these years
for my own individual Legacy and I go
from being a Statesman to a politician
to hey there's no way in the world you
can get me to do XYZ nah listen if you
do that we'll do this no problem and so
how much of this stuff is where you know
a a person is sitting there saying
listen China if you do this I want to be
a president just let me do this how much
how dirty behind closed door does it get
where it's holding people hostage over a
promotion holding people hostage over
what they know of what she did 17 years
ago holding people hostage of saying let
me tell you what I got about you what
happened 18 years ago if you don't keep
your mouth shut that's going to come out
how much of that holding hostage happens
where somebody
Powell you're like what what just
happened to you how did you go from this
to come this doesn't sound like the same
person here how much of that happens
behind closed doors a lot and but it's
not just behind closed doors it happens
in open doors and I think the American
people are starting to see that I mean
it's becoming more and more transparent
why do you have a chairman of Joint
Chiefs of Staff making uh unsolicited
phone calls to the uh General over in
China I mean you you I mean back in the
day I mean you get
you know hold hold up for for treason
you don't do that look
there's too much self-interest and
special interest that's hurting the
United States of America and you just
brought up something great we don't have
Statesmen in States when we have
politicians and the difference between a
Statesman and the politicians that a
politician is going to tell you what
they think you want to hear
because they want to vote
but a Statesman is going to tell you
what you need to hear regardless of the
circumstances and the consequences can
Statesmen get elected today and that's
the problem it comes back to us the
compensation plan is not set up but it's
also you know our societal model is that
we want to be told what we want to hear
what makes us happy what makes us
comfortable
but you've got to be able to look at
yourself in the mirror look I was
redistricted out of this District that I
represented and and I was honored to do
it by Republicans
and I was the first black Republican
member of Congress since reconstruction
now you had have to ask yourself why
would the Republican Party The Party of
Lincoln the party that us you know free
the slaves and everything why would they
take the first black Republican member
from Florida since reconstruction and
redistrict him out and then I was the
number one target for the Democrats in
2012. because people don't want to have
folks to have the courage and the
conviction to stand up and say what
needs to be said
that that that that that shines a light
on them that they're not comfortable
with and and we have got to get a mature
level again it comes back to being
adults Patrick we got to be mature in
America we got to start looking and
saying
AOC
that's the best that we can have in
America you know uh what's the name uh
from Minnesota Omar Omar Omar uh Rashida
Talib Rashida Talib press I mean I can
go down the list and I can go on on the
other side but we we've got to have
people that are concerned I mean Once
Upon a Time you could not be president
of the United States of America if you
had not worn a uniform
if you're not fought in combat you
people would laugh at you
Once Upon a Time 50 years ago over 70
percent of the members of Congress had
served in uniform today that number's
like 18 get out of here
18 to 18 no I'm from 70 yeah 50 years
ago to 18 absolutely go back and look at
that
and and so you know what is happening is
that the people that this country
trusted the people that said you know
I'm going to raise my right hand I'm
going to take a note to support and
defend what the rule of law the
Constitution the United States of
America I'm not taking a note that says
I'm going to support me my pocket these
special interests that come up here
you're right 18.4 percent
the incoming U.S House of Representative
will have 80 members who've served in
the military at some level or 18.4
percent of total membership according to
Pew research that's embarrassing that's
that's embarrassing but but who but but
again that's a reflection of who us as
the American people
you know we've forgotten what leadership
is we we have forgotten what service and
sacrifice and commitment and that that
was you know yesterday was the the 50th
anniversary of the end of the Vietnam
War my older brother came back from
Vietnam and took his dress Marine
uniform and threw it into the closet
and and the most important thing you can
say to a Vietnam veteran is welcome home
because they didn't didn't get to hear
it but we have forgotten about those men
and women and what they are willing to
do with the sacrifices to the point
where now someone can say who cares that
you lost a friend in Afghans who cares
if you lost limbs in Afghanistan I'm
going to give Afghanistan back to the
people that you fought to get out of
power
can you imagine what that means to a
young man or woman that spent years of
their lives over in a place they saw
their buddies die or or like I said lose
limbs and now we put the exact same
people back in charge
and left them your equipment
first of all this is this is staggering
to be thinking about how few people uh
one of the best things that happened to
me the two and a half years I spent in
the Army as a 63 Bravo Hummer mechanic
at Fort Campbell Kentucky AIT and Boot
Camp Jackson 101st Air Assault life
changing I went from a bullion to a man
and I remember drill sergeant Pearl I
befriended him on Facebook 15 years
later I'm like do you remember me at
Drill Sergeant Green drill sergeant all
these guys I remember what they did an
18 year old kid that's undecided on what
to do with their lives with their career
there's a lot military can do for you I
don't know about today's military it's
slightly different today with what
they're doing totally different very
different than than when I went and I
like the fact that they were scream and
hollering challenging you trying to
mentally break you down to see be all
you can be all that you can be in the
Army but here's a question so it's easy
to sit there and say Democrats Democrats
Democrats socialist socialist socialists
all these guys okay I'm a business guy
when I lost market share in a area I
would say what did we do wrong to lose
that market share you know like what did
we do like you're saying this as well
the first thing you talked about is it's
on us Pat it's on you and I what what do
we do why are we allowing this thing to
happen right but some people may say
dude I'm not Karl Rove who was the
strategist
I'm not you know David uh Dave uh who
was the the George Bush the guy that was
a heavyweight guy for many years I'm
forgetting his name the book was written
about a phenomenal book who was his
chief of staff I think the chief of
staff for President Bush what was his
name uh uh uh not not uh anyways I'll
think about the name I'll tell him you
know exactly what I'm talking about uh
uh uh what is what is anyways I'll put
it up I'll give you the name
these guys were strategists behind
closed doors you know these guys could
take somebody and bring them up and
they're saying hey we should do this or
we should do that hey you saw this week
we were talking about Silicon Valley
companies how Larry Ellison and five of
these other companies all use the same
word to say moving forward you're
working from office or you're not
because we need a collaborative
environment for you to work out at the
office you can't do it through Zoom
those guys had a conversation together
and said guys we got to use a similar
word collaborative you see these
channels that say
you know the same phrase and you see one
video One reporter says it then nine
then this and they're all saying the
same thing where did Republicans lose it
what strategy because Democrats
outflanked they had a better strategy
than uh Republicans were their offer was
more attractive to people the last 10 20
30 40 years the Republicans sit on the
sidelines were they getting casual did
they get soft did they not uh really
value the enemy that they think the
enemy is not that important that they
have a blind spot if they did where was
that you know I just finished the book
that was written by a republican
California state Senator H.L Richardson
it's called confrontational politics
you know right now it is less Patrick
about Republican and Democrat it's less
about political parties it is more about
philosophies of governance the United
States of America was founded on a very
incredible revolutionary premise that
the individual is supreme and Sovereign
over the institution of government now
we have people that believe that the
institution of government being at the
federal state local levels are Supreme
and Sovereign over the individual that
they make decisions based upon that
they're more so concerned about how do
we make the individual wedded to us how
do we make the individual dependent upon
us and you can look at the policies that
come forward we have got to get uh to
the point where we go back and talk
about individual rights freedoms
Liberties uh and we have been lacking in
that we we are always chasing the uh the
other side the the left and you know one
of the things the Army taught me you
could carry your three by five cards
around because you know army guys ain't
really smart Air Force guys are real
smart they don't need three by five cars
but army guys got to carry around three
of my five cars let me let me just share
this quote with you this quote is from
the 1950s the uncontested absurdities of
today
are the accepted slogans of tomorrow
they come to be accepted by degrees by
Dent of constant pressure on one side
and constant Retreat on the other until
one day when they are suddenly declared
to be the country's official ideology
wow
1950s Iran
and that's what is happening that's what
you're talking about you're talking
about the last 50 60 70 years slowly but
surely this little incrementalism we
keep creeping along we destroy the
fountain we take over Hollywood we take
over the media you know we take over
every aspect of our operating culture
now we take over the the military
and this is where we find ourselves and
so we don't you know we may be
successful in a political cycle but
we're up against people being in China
Russia whomever and also people here in
the state they don't think in political
Cycles they think the 300 meter Target
remember we used to go to the rifle
range you have 25 meter Target out to
the three they think about the 300 meter
Target if not longer by the way if not
longer but they will you know make sure
the 25 meter Target they're proficient
at it and able to go out to the G and
Putin say 100 years absolutely they're
not going to be alive in 100 years look
how pretty I would be alive in 25. but
the point is look how Tom look how proud
they are of their country that it is
their country they're not going to let
somebody else come and be above it over
their own lives
a hundred years is what they're talking
about and we are what 246 years old
as a nation 43 now 246 247 I think right
yeah 20 23. yeah you said something very
important you use the phrase cultural
Marxism a cultural Marxism really has
two tenets and the first tenant is there
is no absolute truth and the second
tenet is that the state is supreme so
when you take those two Pat they they're
so simple to say and you can put
everything follows underneath it and it
says how do you break you break
religions okay no absolute truth yeah
the state is supreme that's how you
break family that's how you break the
authority of parents that's how you have
the authority over kids those are the
two truths and I look at it and I was
reading this week because we were
looking at all this stuff and I'm like
who is telling
the person that is coming to the United
States today to immigrate you know the
political Refugee or whoever they are
they're coming to this American ideal so
somewhere in the world there is still
this concept of freedom and liberty and
an enablement and I want to go to
America because they're still coming
here and I don't mean the ones that are
being trafficked here Southern border
I'm talking about ones that still
legitimately want to come here for what
it is out there in the world there is a
greater reputation of America than we
have among ourselves you know I had
Gordon Chen on uh during covet two and a
half years he used to live in uh he was
a lawyer in China I think for like 20
years or something like that he said the
one number that's changed Tom a little
bit to pay attention to is before kids
would come from other countries here and
they would go to school here
and then they would say damn this place
is great and then they would stay here
versus now kids are coming here
to our schools learning what we're
teaching them and now they're taking
what we taught them back to their
countries yeah so meaning the brightest
are no longer staying there going back
that's the argument that he was making
that they're now able to bring him back
to their country versus before now you
can look at the statistics of China
their net migration right now is
negative they're losing people I don't
know if you saw the stats for 2022
wasn't a good look they're losing people
so is Russia Russia lost a lot of people
that left them as well so some can say
statistically you know you know Russia
there it is so current net migration
rate for China 2023 minus 0.256 per
thousand population uh a 0.79 increase
from 2029 net migration for China is do
you have the one for Russia as well
because I think both of them are down
they're not looking good well you're
looking this up remember this comes out
of readily available country information
the actual truth of these numbers is
probably higher because China and Russia
are skewing down the numbers they report
well this is you have 2022 which you
don't have Is 2020 uh 2022 was 0.78 per
thousand a decline of 14.42
and you know it's going to be higher
this year as well obviously with what's
going on there but America is still that
country but
um
I you know you know sometimes when
you're Mike Tyson
and you go into a ring people are
shivering they're shaking they're like
oh my God
it's Mike and you're debating do I buy
this pay-per-view or not because it's
going to be less than 30 seconds is it
worth it and guess what guys if you're
going to come over to watch the fight
bring dominoes bring Scrabble bring
Spades because we're probably going to
be playing cards we're only going to be
watching a fight for less than a minute
okay and then this guy shows up that he
proved the Tyson is
Buster Douglas syndrome right and he
comes in like
this guy can be beat what are you
talking about right
and then next thing you know Holyfield
couple other guys they're like oh you
know I can get them Jon Jones has proven
he's the scariest man in the world
he looked out of shape this time some
people said there's no way this guy's
gonna be you know or whatever yeah and I
was kind of like concerned because I'm
like I've not seen this guy be this
heavy for a long time yeah boom what
does he do wasn't even close right they
still fear this man the problem with
America is if America was a fighter the
last few years America's had losses in
the ring and people don't fear America
anymore and we've allowed that to become
a reality that's my only concern when
you walk into a bar and everybody knows
you are America and everybody kind of
like hey hey hey guys listen us is here
now it's kind of like hey yeah what's up
how you doing you want a drink get them
a drink on us yeah you don't talk to
America like that now they are yeah how
do we get here who's sitting at this bar
stool uh you are sir yeah it's very
simple how we got here Ronald Reagan
once coined the phrase peace through
strength and we don't believe that
strength is something we should embrace
we shouldn't embrace you know Kumbaya
and we have allowed people to become
near peers you know in the Middle East I
remember when when I was in Iraq in in
2003 and I was just north of Baghdad and
as a matter of fact I was at the
intersection where the road came from
ramadi and Fallujah hit Highway one and
went into the SUNY triangle we called it
the hot corner so I sat down and said
well I gotta you know I gotta meet the
shakes out here because I I got to let
these guys know you know that I'm here
and who I am and it was about 45 to 50
shakes that we've got together and the
the senior Chic or whatever you want to
call the most respected guy pulled me
off to the side for the meeting and
Through The Interpreter he said that
everyone here is looking for one thing
out of you we're not too strong
if you're strong that you'll be able to
control this area if you're not strong
they're going to run all over you and
that's what people understand there are
people that only understand in the world
strength and might
you know compromise appeasement
negotiation sending them billions of
dollars in an unmarked dark doubt plane
in the middle of the night that is
weakness and what they see coming out in
the White House what they see coming out
of our foreign policy and again I come
back to the debacle in Afghanistan
that's weakness and weakness is enticing
and that's where we are and when they
can read and pull down what you have up
here they can see what's happening in
our military Ronald Reagan had our
surface warship Fleet of the United
States Navy at about 575 warships
the low point we were down to 235 just
recently now we're trying to get back
over 300. now I'm going to say something
that hurts me as a soldier but it's true
how do you extend
the hegemonic dominance of a Nation it
ain't through an army
it's through a Navy
the Athenians were more powerful than
the Spartans the Spartans were great you
know warriors on on land but the
Athenians could extend their power
and so you think about any time you see
a country that is heavily involved in
growing their Maritime Fleet
last time it happened in Asia who was it
and it's happening again
China is outpacing our Navy
because they see that it is weakness and
that's how they can go all over the
world and start pushing their policies
and agendas because they see weakness we
got a window and if we don't correct
this window 2024 is a pivotal election
cycle I hate to put it there but it's a
pivotal election future why because if
we continue down this path we're done
it may not be recoverable it really may
not be every every four years I hear
that okay and I want to push back but
the numbers the numbers speak to it you
know in two and a half years you've gone
from uh 1.4 inflation to over six
percent inflation hard water mark was
9.1 inflation and even people say well
that's because of Russia it was seven
points something percent before even
Russia you've gone from six percent GDP
down to what less than two percent GDP
you're decimating your military you're
going from energy Independence to energy
dependence I mean I can just tick it off
all the way down our economics uh
security and our our uh all in in energy
security you've got a border I mean I
mean can we take another four years on
top of this with what another what 10
million people coming across the board
illegally not just the southern border
but now the northern border that's why
I'm saying that this is a critical
election cycle because the numbers and
the facts point to this is unsustainable
okay so if if you're if you're right you
know the whole thing where uh you got
Bush you got Clinton you got Clinton
Clinton didn't hate America though no I
don't I agree but but what I'm saying is
you got senior which is Bush okay then
you got Clinton yeah okay after Clinton
you got Bush after Bush you got Obama
after Obama you got Trump after Trump
you got Biden right every for the last
six presidents the only one is Reagan
Reagan did such a great job that people
said we just want another Reagan we'll
take his replacement which is what his
VP bring him in so typically if the VP
becomes it maybe they kind of trusted
what that situation was
but how much of a good job are
Republicans doing at presenting the
argument to say they're not okay so
that's why so if their messaging sucks
so if their messaging sucks did you
watch so so let me just ask the question
about Trump and uh DeSantis how do you
feel about their chances right now
winning 2024 Trump and the Santas I will
tell you what I hear all over the
country is that people are looking for
something to get away from this Bond
Administration but they don't want the
drama
they just want people they're going to
go in and fix these things that we're
talking about but but let me give you a
great case in point what you're talking
about the debt of the United States
America when I came into Congress from
right here south Florida in 2011 was 14
trillion dollars
2011. was it today today 32. and that's
Republicans Democrats remember what I
said this is not about party it's about
philosophy of governance it's about
understanding that the individual your
rights freedoms of Liberty our our small
business free market entrepreneurship
program that is Supreme Over the the
government and the government's supposed
to set the conditions for that success
it doesn't matter r d there are some
very simple and and you said it perfect
they're objective truths out there that
work and when you don't do objective
truth then you get baths up I Love
College Football in college football I
don't care what kind of play you draw up
if you don't block and tackle you lose
we're not blocking and tackling and
that's that's a bipartisan issue and so
we have got to again comes back to us we
have got to elect the people they're
going to go up there and do what is
right by America and be focused on these
these issues that are confronting us and
get the policies back in place without
all the the the extraneous you know uh
uh uh White Noise this that's going on
but
this is a critical time for this country
uh because there's no aspect of our
operating systems right now that are
functional now okay so so you're saying
that let me let me keep going with this
story here until we go to the next one
so here's a story by
uh the hill Biden tops Trump by two
points in hypothetical 2024 matchup
Trails DeSantis a new quinnipi quinnipeg
uh University poll finds that President
Biden is a in close hypothetical races
with two leading candidates Republican
parties 2024 nomination Biden leads
former president Trump in a hypothetical
2024 rematch with 48 support to Trump's
46 in a hypothetical election between
Biden and Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
the other front running for GOP Biden
Trails 46 to desantises 48. the poll
found Trump leading DeSantis in a
head-to-head but behind with the former
president earning 52 percent to the
sentence is 42 Biden Trump and the
scientists all at similar favorable
meetings amongst registered voters with
37 percent having a favorable view of
Biden 36 percent of trump and 36 percent
of descent so in this case they're
saying Trump beats DeSantis but Trump
doesn't beat Biden and if DeSantis wins
DeSantis could beat Biden how aligned
are you with what this poll is shown no
I I think that that poll is very
accurate what is out there and it's
interesting that you know Ron DeSantis
has those numbers he hadn't even
declared and so I think that you will
see an improvement in his numbers if he
declare look Ron DeSantis won the State
of Florida in his first election by less
than one percent over Andrew Gillum
right oh Andrew Gill mayor of
Tallahassee what was the thing that took
Ron DeSantis over the top and brought
single black mothers to vote for him
educational Freedom school choice that
that is the Forefront issue right now if
Donald Trump would have said it was him
though yeah well that's the thing
leadership is not about first person
singular and if I could if he was
sitting right there I'd tell him that
you got to stop using first person
singular because that's not how you lead
people that's how you get the attention
on you but now that's been signed into
law here in in in Florida and when he
came back for his re-election I mean he
won Palm Beach County he won Miami-Dade
County he won by almost 20 percent it
never happens where Republican carries
Miami-Dade County never one and a half
million by one and a half million votes
he'd be now Dems will say Charlie Chris
has hands down the worst candidate in
the history of mankind every single so
is Joe Biden and and again you know
Charlie Chris was out there touting the
policies woke stuff and all this other
stuff that of Joe Biden the American
people were rejected if they had
something clear to this it's just just
the same as Jimmy Carter coming out in
Ronald Reagan remember that Ronald
Reagan commercial this morning in
America who could not vote for that
there was only one state in the United
States of America never voted for Ronald
Reagan that was Minnesota did you see
did you see yeah that's right 49 out of
50. and by the way Carter is the Biden
is the closest thing to Carter if not
well he's not yet worse data wise but
he's worse than other ways at least
Carter was liked and you know he thought
it was a man a Navy Submariner uh
Academy graduate no one could sit and
say Carter hated America just the same
as Bill Clinton Bill Clinton pivoted
after his midterm debacle people will
say Bill Clinton loved women more than
America
I defer to that
American women but yeah they were
American women but Bill Clinton Bill
Clinton is the
guy that was good
that may be one of your best he didn't
like them first
[Laughter]
Thomas but you were saying Clinton
America I agree but Bill Clinton is the
guy who stood up in a stadium Union
address and said the era big government
is over
do you think a Democrat could stand up
in the State of Union address and say
that no and so that that's why you know
the blue dog demon conservative demon
whatever you want to call it they don't
exist anymore but the thing is that we
have to run on these issues we have to
get out there and find out what are the
the things that you just you know talked
about earlier what brings us together
how can we Galvanize ourselves and and I
will tell you the the issue of Education
galvanizes this country it really does
because I think that parents are
concerned about the future for their
children
look at look at these inner cities I
mean Chicago Baltimore these kids cannot
function math and English a grade level
some fully agree with you I think I
think
the education in kids is is not a
Republican or Democratic argument it's
all across the board just like Roe v
Wade if you notice the stats on the
midterms was like Hey you know this is
something that if you pushed it the way
you did you know they said McConnell did
this to kind of hurt Trump's uh look to
say he lost on you read all those
stories you know what I'm talking about
but there's certain things that the
American people are saying leave this
alone we're kind of at this point here I
think education is being one of them but
but I want to continue did you see
DeSantis on uh Pierce Morgan yeah you
watch the whole interview well not the
whole interview zero to ten what are you
giving
I give him uh 7.5 okay do you think he
to win at the next level uh like you
know you read the story about Roger
Ailes how Roger Ailes went to Nixon in
1960 and said you know why you lost you
lost because you need a guy like me I'm
Gonna Be Your what you're right
whatever and you need me to come in here
media coach and then he came in and
helped him out in the Nixon one and he
did the same thing with McConnell saying
real the fishing dumb you know it's like
so McConnell wins great documentary does
it with Sean Hannity and all these guys
a divide and conquer documentary
explains the whole story right
do you think
charm and Charisma selling yourself
today is important for the centers to be
able to win it or do you think
America is going to be okay to say no we
just want a guy that's going to get the
job done we don't care if a guy wants to
go out there and Shake Hands Biz Dev no
do any of that stuff do you think that's
necessary or not Americans are visual
Americans want folks to show whether
they like uh look go back in the the the
televised debate between Nixon and
Kennedy uh if you listen to it don't
look at it he listened to it it was it
was Nixon but the fact that Nixon looked
like he had five o'clock Shadows you
know Kennedy look young and in fact you
know Abraham Lincoln Abraham Lincoln
probably couldn't make it today and even
back then uh they said ape you gotta
kind of like grow a beard because your
face it looks too Squad and everything
all his pictures he had the high collar
to to reduce the length of his neck I
mean America's visual go back to 2012 in
the election between Mitt Romney and uh
and Barack Obama the exit polls everyone
said who would have been better to
handle the comment Mitt Romney but who
did you like Barack Obama so there is an
aspect of it and what I what I tell
people all the candidates to say Hey you
know I'd like to get your endorsement
can you tell me what image and message
those are the two aspects of a person
running for office or campaign whatever
image and message the other side always
wins on image
because their message sucks
but people are so
focused on their image I mean Barack
Obama I mean you looked at them on
television and you're just like wow but
it's the same thing you see every single
Sunday in the black church you know the
very charismatic pastor and everything
like that but if you just read a speech
Barack Obama you would say what in this
what is he talking about it's the same
thing with with with Biden in a way so
his image was horrible so they put him
in the basement
and nobody talked about anything what
did they do they attacked the image of
Donald Trump so yes you've got to go and
and look at the the charismatic aspect
of leadership but I wrote this down
because I knew you're going to come to
that leadership is about what the Army
taught me five C's
the first C is courage
people want to see a courageous person
they want to see a courageous leader the
second C is competence
because as you know no one follows a
dummy into a firefight so they want to
know they have a competent leader the
next C is commitment a commitment to a
core set of principles and values I mean
you can say what you want about Ronald
Reagan but you know he was committed to
America he was committed to the
Constitution he was committed to our
fundamental principles and values then
you got to be convicted that's the
fourth C because even when the winds
blow the polls say this whatever you got
to stay true north leaders stay true
north they committed to something and
they're convicted to and then the last
thing is character doing what is right
when no one's watching that's what I
taught soldiers that's what I taught my
daughter's five C's courage competence
commitment conviction and character
and when you understand that and you you
realize okay the two-faced image and
message and you bring all that together
you're powerful you're you're going to
win 49 out of 50. so what are you saying
about DeSantis to me has all five of
those I think he's got courage I think
he's got confidence I think he's got
commitment I think his he is conviction
he's got conviction I think he's a man
of character I think he's got those
things but this is a difference I want
to show you this this is Dr Albert
mehrabian's uh uh uh uh uh
738-55 Rule and I don't know if it's his
or somebody else's but I've seen this
and I've read this in books you've seen
it as well seven percent is a spoken
word today elements of communication 38
is voice and tone five fifty five
percent is body language
does this favor DeSantis this is one and
you're gonna identify with this
remember when you first reported into a
unit yes I remember when officers
reported into me clearly knock on the
door they come in you're sizing them up
they're not saying anything you're
looking at their uniform you're looking
at their boots especially looking at
their haircut the comportment and
everything and then when they stand
before you they open up their mouth it
either confirms or denies that 55 so
what are you saying what I'm saying is
that you've got to have that visual
appearance first and foremost well he
has the appearance and and I think that
everything falls from that it's just the
same as if I came in here and you know
I'm Lieutenant Carl retired Alan
Westwood I'm sitting over here with a
beard I'm 200 pounds overweight you're
gonna say what kind of curl was that guy
you know so you you have to present that
r that atmosphere I mean again Ronald
Reagan you know his body language his
his his physical presence he was an
actor he knew how to sell it comes back
what I say image and message and you've
got to win the image battle really
before you get to the message battle
which is what you say so so I'm again I
want to go back to it does have the
complete package to win on the big stage
with the camera on him 24 7 having to
show some charm some Charisma some
vulnerability likability instead of just
he does yes I I absolutely believe he
does and what's even better you know
what his greatest asset is
results his wife
who was in the media
and so she will make sure he knows how
to do you know bring that all together
that that's his wife you're saying yeah
that's that's as great and some people
said it wasn't a good look the way he
did media and I look I'll go to America
but I know I saw him but he's got to
learn that I mean is that enough to
learn in a year he ain't got that much
time because before he announces it you
know there's a difference between going
against the crisp there's I think the
last time he had a real battle was
Gillum more than it was Chris right so
you know does you remember when uh uh
Rick Perry came out I remember that's
going to be the president he's going to
be president the three different three
agencies oops oh man this guy's done and
he was on fire going to California if
you're sick and tired of Regulation come
to Texas we'll know how to take care of
him like I'm going to Texas I want to
met with him we're at a Texas Rangers
gonna discuss freaking amazing the charm
the Charisma this guy could be a
president one day boom doesn't happen
because of that so there's a difference
between big stage and well I agree you
know so this is the part where there are
a lot of people that want this guy to do
it there are a lot of people that want
this kid to pull it off there's a lot
that wandy but in business and in
leadership there's a difference between
wanting a guy because you'll like him so
much and it actually happened and it
ends up being another guy that maybe you
don't like that much sometimes it's
confusing
well yes but I will tell tell you that
if you make a mistake but people feel it
was an honest mistake and you own it the
American people are forgiving uh but if
you make a mistake and you're arrogant
about it uh they're not going to be so
forgiving and that's that's part of this
I don't think people are looking for
that perfect person uh I don't think
that that perfect candidate is what I'm
saying though because I think because I
because I actually think if if we are
looking for more the perfect person he
is more perfect then Trump is perfect
Trump has a hundred times more
imperfections than this guy's does we
can name different girls and we can go
through the imperfection list right so a
lot of people could say Trump is more
imperfect and he's perfect the other way
around so but to me I'm not coming from
policy I'm not coming from there's a
whole different criticism to say this
guy's more The Establishment than Trump
is and while we're going through a
season like this where you're talking
about China Iran Russia Saudi Juan you
know Ukraine Russia when you know what's
going on there Afghanistan stand you
know Taliban everybody's attacking us
internally the swamp dude you this there
needs to be somebody that's gone through
God knows how many different ways of
negotiation and the streets of New York
real estate some people are saying if
you are saying Alan the problem in the
world is so bad you need a scary type of
guy where they fear well the other side
is going to say holy [__] this is not
the one guy I want to face off I would
much rather take a guy that knows how to
follow the guidelines to move up in his
career than another guy that's broken
the rules every once in a while where he
may be willing to go places that others
are not willing to go this guy doesn't
seem like he's here and what you just
did you you made the argument for a
George Patton George Patton had all kind
of flaws Eisenhower I mean he drove
patent drove Eisenhower crazy
but Patton understood one thing George
Patton won
and he knew that he needed him uh maybe
sometimes he had to put him in time out
like what you saw after the little
soldier slapping incident but he knew he
had to bring him off Sidelines and get
him back into the fight so you've read
the book Lincoln on leadership by Donald
D Phillips I think it's Donald Phillips
and he chapter 11 where he says search
until you find your Grant
and he has this guy named McClellan you
know yeah absolutely phenomenal right
but he was the trainer yeah he was a
thinker but he was a trainer he wasn't a
doer he wasn't a field General and then
he gets this guy never reports anything
back never tells him what's going on he
can't find where Grant is he's talking
about grants drinking he's doing this
he's doing that but at the end of the
day he wins he freaking wins becomes one
of the worst Presidents we've had he was
not necessarily the best president
interim president but he was a great
exchange leg for you know Lincoln hey
you do your part you win the war you
make make us look good you be the
president it kind of worked out for him
but to me I'm wondering if we have a
situation here like that I may be wrong
uh at the end of the day anything is
better than what we have today correct
anything is better than what we have
today
um you know Bill Maher the other day
called Trump he says I think Trump is
the greatest politician of all time he
says and I don't even think he knows
that he's a great greatest politician of
all time I don't even think he knows
that he knows what he's doing but he's
the greatest politician of all time he
said this on the show last week said
there is gamesmanship here Alan this is
a dark world so for me if you're gonna
call a guy to be your captain you have
to make sure that Captain uh knows the
dirty side when I ran a small office
and I was an agent selling Insurance
nobody cared about me
Patrick's a nice guy
then when I ran a top office Insurance
in San Fernando Valley
people outside of San Fernando Valley
love me but people in San Fernando
Valley didn't like me so if I wanted
them all and I saw a competitor you
mother Fiero because I'm a direct
competitor but in San Fernando Valley we
all went to the same church we all went
to the same gyms the same LA Fitness the
same this the same that
so then all of a sudden I'm competing in
the state
then it's regional then it's National
the moment we became National and then
we started writing two three thousand
policies a month then I all of a sudden
realize [__]
sting is real yeah a lot of these guys
were all sympathetic in understanding
why you're so great and now it's like
they're calling other insurance
companies for me to lose my contract got
it so this is the game sh I gotta go
read a bunch of war books yeah I got to
go read a bunch of 33 Strategies who are
the war power books then I understood
the game so the next level he's gonna go
into is gonna be a thousand times darker
than what it was on covet and if the
American people are going to say he's
the guy great I think he is a man of
character I think he is fully a man who
loves America I think he is a tough guy
but uh it'll be interesting how the
American American voter whether they
pick him and by the way it's still too
early to tell anyways everybody right
now is saying oh it's done Trump's going
to win the whole thing he's going to be
the president I don't think it's going
to be that way
because I think there's more dark
strategies that they have up their
sleeves that we don't know about but
that is the concern of a lot of people
when I talk to them well it's a
two-person race on the Republican side I
don't I don't care what you know all
these other folks that are jumping in
there a bit what three percent here two
percent there it's a two-person race
they're all racing for VP positions they
won't say that but without a doubt yeah
and you just brought up a great point it
really is about who you surround
yourself with
you know in the military a general is
only as good as the staff
and so if if you want to give counsel to
a guy like a Rhonda Sanders you better
pick the right staff to go around you to
get you ready to to go out there uh to
be on this big stage and and I would
make the same offer to president Trump
president Trump made some bad choices
and Selections in the people that he
surrounded himself with in his term in
office so learn from that and get the
right type of people around you because
I think that it's so important that you
have someone I I never wanted an XO an
S3 or definitely a sergeant major I
don't want to Sergeant Major told me
everything I want to hear I wanted to
Sergeant Major to pull me out to the
size of Colonel
you're about to screw this up let me
tell you something and he would never do
it in public of course but disarm age is
my right hand man that's that's why
that's why he was the sergeant major so
Trump needs a sergeant major
DeSantis needs a sergeant major
and hopefully they will go out and find
that person that's going to tell them
you know unequivocally you're screwing
this up but here's how you can fix it I
don't want to put words in your mouth
but it it sounds like you're more on a
DeSantis Camp than a trump camp at this
point would I be fair in saying that I'm
on a camp that's focused on fixing
correcting policy and solutions I don't
want the camp that's out there going you
know with the Mickey Mouse stuff I I
don't have time for the Mickey Mouse
stuff I see where this country is headed
I see what we're confronting against and
you're right there's some dark enemies
out there and we have to have someone
day one they can start going right at
this thing and getting it right and and
just push the media to the side don't
don't get involved with all of that
backbiting stuff right there you got to
be focused on the things that the
American people going to ask you to do
which is to protect their life their
Liberty their property Pursuit of
Happiness let me let me ask this
question Tom and then I'm going to go to
you first okay Megan Kelly set the
following she said Megan Kelly slams
DeSantis for rejecting an interview he
is afraid now making Kelly we know is
not for Trump and everybody knows that
if there's a person she's not for so
she's not a lobbying because she's
trying to get closer to
Trump that's got to be ever since that
first debate stage yeah exactly coming
from everywhere yeah Megan Kelly
revealed the Monday episode that Megan
Kelly showed that Ron DeSantis the
Florida governor and like the 2024
presidential candidate has been turning
down her request to interview him uh on
her Sirius XM show suggesting that he's
afraid of her interview style Kelly
refused to soften questions to
presidential candidates and explained
that reporters are there for the viewers
not the candidates and journalists need
to be adversarial with interviewees
Kelly concluded by saying it to
discussed her watching The Press running
cover for Biden and hardcore Maga group
running cover for Trump and that reports
reporters should stop falling in love
with politicians and grow pair because
their business is not to be louder to
tell the truth respect will get
reporters and audience love is for
pundits who just want to say nice sweet
nothing so what do you think about what
she says here I think she's right oh go
to Tom Tom what are your thoughts on
this I think she's absolutely right and
she makes an important point and what
you've both been talking about in this
whole
the line of leadership here when you
look around the world stage the greatest
compliment our adversaries have given
U.S presidents
is when thus say he's crazy
when Reagan was about to be elected you
saw the Arab world particularly Iraq
saying that guy's crazy and that's
because they didn't want to articulate
Their Fear in public they said he's
crazy when you look at it you look at
the
um the the people that surrounded the
emperor of Japan we now see through
Memoirs and things that come out when
Truman dropped those bombs now those
were dropped on Military and civilian
targets and it's horrible it's a
horrible moment in history that it had
to happen that way but they all told the
emperor FDR is dead Truman's crazy
and that is where you know it's it's
sort of the the doctrine of Kaiser so
say if you ever remember the
Untouchables they said the will to do
one more thing that the other guy won't
and unusual suspects yes that's right
right unusual suspects and I think
that's the usual suspects you know where
I went with that sorry about that but I
think what Megyn Kelly is asking for is
like hey I'm not here for your talking
points I'm trying to identify a leader
that's kind of what I see because I see
a certain Purity in Megan Kelly's
approach is that if you get through that
Gauntlet you come out with a lot of
respect and she's not there I think to
play I don't disagree with her though
you know I don't disagree with that I'm
saying yeah I don't disagree with her I
think there's a part and by the way by
the way I I don't think it's gonna work
for him
I don't think it's going to work for him
to do the following okay for example you
know the strategy of because Ron is
using Biden's strategy there's no
strategy different than he's now using
Trump strategy he's using Biden's
strategies you keep a low profile what's
fighting strategy I'm telling you if you
watch Pierce Morgan's interview you can
tell a guy's interview on him who would
rather have him than Trump you can tell
in the interview that it's a soft
interview yeah he brings some stuff up
but he it's very obvious for somebody
that's an interviewer you know how an
interview is done where it's like if
you're here let's just say you're trying
to be as neutral and moderate as
possible with anybody you're
interviewing okay if we know five
percent you're for the guy we're okay
with it that's fine I can respect that
but if you do an interview and you go 25
this set you're not doing it or you're
hanging out with a friend is what you're
doing right that was a 25 interview of
what he did Pierce Morgan did an
interview with Andrew Tate it was sick
because he pushed him and then Andrew
had to kind of defend himself so
piercers are there one of the best
interviewers in the world but for me
DeSantis is using Biden's strategy
because he's avoiding the hot seat and
Trump is going to come out and say if
you just want to go interview with
people that you like
that's that's Biden 2.0 what DeSantis is
doing DeSantis needs to go do some real
interviews that's going to be
uncomfortable a part of thing to me you
know who I put the blame on that
is I'm going to go where you went but
you gave credit but I'm not giving
credit you know where I'm going with
this
exactly I'm going to who's his press
secretary
it ain't no Christina Pusha or the new
guy that he has you know whoever it is
right something his press secretary is
Casey but see I would I would think that
she would you know train him and get him
to understand that you know let me do
some mock interviews with you now let me
let me let me throw don't think they've
done it well I don't know it for sure
they've done well I would hope so I mean
I've seen some you know you've seen some
bright lights when he has had some of
these press conferences and leftist
media has attacked him it's great though
but that's when he wins I know but
that's what I'm saying I I think that
that's the asset that can help him that
it's just like when I became uh you know
selected for a battalion command I had
to go through time command charm school
and part of Battalion command charter
school was media relations and you had
to sit in there you got a scenario and
and an incident that happened and you
had a mock media yeah and they came at
you man and I was like dang this is this
is they don't want it they redirect you
and so you have to be able to be on and
that's why I think she could be that
asset for him but if she's not the
sergeant mate see she's not the sergeant
major if she's just playing you know
cheerleaders you know what it is though
well here's what it is so you're a
colonel so I salute you I'm a 44 year
old specialist is the most I made it so
The Specialist gave me more headaches
Lieutenant Colonel P Cox is who changed
my life yeah till today I wish I could
find this man Lieutenant Colonel
peacocks is a man that changed my life
he was one of the men that changed my
life I really respected the way he led
me a 20 year old kid he was a good man
changed my life in a big way but but
here's the thing
so let's just say
you report to me hypothetically and
you're 25 I'm 35. you're a fighter okay
it's very obvious you're a fighter I'm
gonna read that very quickly okay so and
I know potentially you have what it
takes to be a major Lieutenant Colonel
you got a big upside right and you're
not even a second Lieutenant right now
maybe you're an E6 E5 you're about to
become a second Lieutenant your father
is going to come and put that on you
it's a special moment that you're going
to have you're the E5 E6
I'm going to put you in positions to
fight because you are a fighter I think
we just watched Creed the other day
we're in the Iraqi series with the kids
I have to go through all of them I've
watched this thing so many times but I
have to go through because I got two
sons eleven and nine and they want to go
throughout once we watch one the mission
impossible we're going through 73 of
them right so however many they got so
and in Creed there's a couple parts
where it's like you know where Rocky
takes responsibility for allowing Creed
to fight Drago and he says as a corner
man it was my fault and he was kind of
afraid of it right
I think the corner man here is her
and she has to let him go fight more of
these fights and the longer you go
here's the problem
the longer you delay this announcement
and you go it's gonna take three months
of 20 hardcore interviews to make you
ready for the stage I don't understand
this concept like this is the part about
dude you don't know the like as smart as
you and I may be and we can come up with
93 of all the questions people can ask
you you don't know the seven percent we
need the seven percent yeah and the
seven percent are gonna get us to go to
a Megan Kelly is to come over here and
sit down with us and have a conversation
it's not to go to people that are loving
you they're going to vote for you that's
not how you win Trump the reason why
Trump got the credit that he got from
everybody ask me any interview Anytime
Anyplace let's roll you don't have to
like that guy you just have to say this
[__] you know yeah he's willing
to go anywhere but at least there's the
respect and the fear because he's saying
I don't fear you he says go ahead what
do you want to say hey Trump do you have
any uh are you a second amendment guy
yes I am do you own any guns I do you go
out shooting it's none of your business
yeah but how do you feel about the
second what's your question get it out
there do you even know what you want to
ask so now the interviewers are scared
of the guest yeah versus in a situation
like this you can't ever pose yourself
as you're afraid of the interviewer the
interviewer has to walk in and be like
oh [__] I'm interviewing a heavyweight
am I going to be ready or is this guy
going to school me the sentence is not
giving that energy out I I don't I don't
know if you understand what I'm saying I
did Carrie Lake you ever seen Carrie
Lake she's a beast try to get cornered
in the hallway and she tops and turns
and says excuse me yeah your publication
said this two weeks ago and you said
this thing I don't appreciate it well
well what you're talking about is that
you never win on defense
you only win by seizing the initiative
Carpe Diem and going on offense and and
that's basically what the the military
teaches there's no battle that's ever
been won on defense I mean even if you
have a successful defense you got a
counter attack if you want to drive the
enemy off the battlefield call over on
Causeway said that war is about the
imposition of your will on your enemy
and and so that's how you have to start
looking at this and and you're bringing
up a great point you know how do you
impose your will out there how do you
make sure that you're imposing your
message how do you come across is that
really figure of strength and might that
people can rally behind and that's what
America is going to be like how did
America learn about you I'm not going to
learn about you the the 13 14 15 years
ago when he gave that Revolution message
I don't know if you know what you're
showing I'm talking about yeah that went
viral it's all tens of hundreds of
millions of views everyone's like who is
this guy military know who you were Army
knew who you were but the rest of us
didn't know who you were we're like damn
I like this guy he's a freaking fighter
this guy sounds like he could be a
governor or president one day that's
what we want to see the guys that are
going to be voting in are going to be
talking about you I think
we have a fighter here his name is
Rhonda santis I think his corner is
holding him back and I think his Corner
needs to realize this man knows how to
fight has he have you asked him to come
on I have asked him to come on the show
and I've even asked him to hold a
fundraiser at the house I have no
problem holding a fundrais at their
house give me the number we'll go raise
it for you and he's actually done
fundraisers in our community he's got
the open invitation we've had the
conversation come down I'll bring 20
influencers that are people that have a
lot of views and they're in the
independent side these would be good
guys to get on your side he's got the
full imitate Christina push out was here
I've spoken to his people we've sent the
invite we've sent the email all of it
but I feel there's somebody behind
closed doors I've already hinted who I
think it is that is holding him back not
in a negative way and a way of trying to
be too perfect with your strategy but I
think it's going to backfire because
DeSantis is a brawler this guy's a not a
pansy he is a fighter he's a brawler but
let him show his brawling abilities
that's how America fell in love with him
in two and a half years when there was a
fight during covet we learn about this
guy I think we need to let him loose a
little bit you know yeah you bring up a
great point that you cannot sit around
when we would go out to training
rotations National Training Center joint
Readiness Training Center the people
that will always lose the commanders
that would always lose were the ones to
set back and try to come up with a 100
plan
and what they taught you at these places
that if you quickly come up with a 70
plan
but you executed to 100 Perfection
meaning that you are the one on the
battlefield that can quickly adjust that
you're taking in all of the branches and
sequels then you're going to be
successful so I see what you're saying
is that Governor desandes don't sit
around and try to be perfect don't try
to be cute come up and be yourself
and and on top of that have the plan to
be able to go out and be successful
understand that you're going to have to
you know be able to adjust improvise
adapt and overcome but that's the
essence of a true leader because in
combat you can come up with the greatest
plan ever Tom but you know who has a
vote
the enemy
and as we say you know uh no plan
survives first Contact but at least you
got to have a base structure of what you
want to go into it and and look you know
I I sat back and watched your interviews
before I came in and that's because I
got to study I gotta understand where
I'm coming into and and you know I just
sat out and you know hear my little
notes and whatever because I've got to
be able to quickly adjust off of what
you're saying you're a fighter though
that's what yeah no you're a fighter
though and so I can't stand it that's
just who I am but I think the scientist
is a fighter yeah I think Trump is a
fighter and FYI for me this is going to
sound weird to a lot of people I will do
fundraiser for Trump
I will do a fundraiser for DeSantis I
will do fundraiser for Biden confusing
ain't it and I would bring the same
exact 20 people and I would say see if
you can win these guys over because if
Biden comes to our house and we raise
the money for you tell us what the
numbers they're going to say dude this
guy doesn't seem presidential hey that's
what happens but we got you the money
what's the number half a million here's
a half a million the 20 people are going
to go and say dude I thought he was
impressive he's not I like them but this
guy can't be the president it's not the
case or he's going to say this guy's
pretty impressive this isn't about me
picking favorites right now we need a
fighter today because the war is real
the enemy is massive and they're
unifying during the time like this which
I do believe when I was pushing back on
the four years I do believe this is the
most important time at least in my
lifetime I don't think this is a time to
be fooling around I think we need to be
doing a better job selling the urgency
and I don't see urgency from the centers
that's all I'm saying if you really are
gonna do it what what see what month are
we right now what is it is it it's okay
April you got what April you got 15
months when is your legislative session
in because that's what everyone's saying
is he doesn't want to announce to the
Legends I think that's in May I want to
say okay well Pat can I ask you a
question yeah in regards to essentially
we started this conversation with Megan
Kelly and going into enemy territory
versus playing it safe to Santas
I'm trying to Rack my brain I can only
think of two politicians in the last
five ten years who will go into enemy
territory but it hasn't necessarily
worked out well with them in the last
two election Cycles the only two
politicians that come to mind are Trump
and Bernie Sanders right Biden's not
going to enemy territory Obama would
barely even go on Bill Maher and that's
the guy a guy guy would agree with him
so we're questioning Ron DeSantis
whether he should go into quote unquote
enemy territory and not like he'd be
coming on valuetamin BB podcast enemy
Territory full support over here for
DeSantis the question is playing it safe
is that Biden played it safe not full
support for DeSantis no I'm just saying
it meaning for you you're the same I'm
going with the Santa's hundred but to me
you know what I am I'm not a DeSantis
I'm not a trump guy I'm not I'm a guy
that is showing strength to face
four real enemies today that is not
afraid to back down and if you're gonna
play this card now then that means
that's how you're going to lead as a
politician when you become a president
you're going to be too overly strategic
being too overly strategic means you may
win but America doesn't win dude you got
to get a black eye go get a couple black
guys I'm sorry the way you brawl is this
is not a dude you're not going into a
fight where it's like okay throw Jabs
and boom boom great I won't buy points
this is not a winning by Point situation
today this is a brawl today this is a
Mickey Ward against Gotti fight today
this is a Trilogy of these guys that
went to freaking Roberto Duran going up
against this is a war you can't be
effing around right now playing too much
strategy I I don't think this is the
season to do it the American people are
sitting there every everybody left
center right sitting there saying what
the hell is going on with China what the
hell is going on with Russia what the
hell is going on with us I'm afraid we
can't be like so yeah so here's what I
would no no that's not I think America
is looking for a guy to come out and say
here's what we got to be doing showing
toughness showing I'm Not Afraid showing
you think if you're afraid of
interviewers what the f what do you
think these other guys are you gonna
face those are not interviewers those
are flatterers that are going to come
and play games they think Putin is an
interviewer you think she's an
interviewer what do you think those guys
going to be doing and interviewers one
one million of a strength of a freaking
enemy you're going to be facing she's
not an interviewer he will dismantle
America if he wants to so I think I
think we need strength whoever's going
to be able to present that salute more
power you're so correct I mean and I go
back to Reagan and a lot of people
weren't born but go back and look at
history you know Reagan you know all of
Europe all of Europe done what those
Pershing missiles there and he got what
was it helmet coal I'm a call German
Chancellor and he says listen I'm
putting them in and I can we can put
them in cooperatively or I can just put
them on my own basis
because we had bases in Germany we had
Spangler Air Force Base and true Germany
with and he put him there and Reagan
goes to Iceland to Reykjavik why did
Gorbachev go to Reykjavik
because he was scared to death of the
Pershing missiles and he believed Reagan
had the will
and when they left Reykjavik and
remember the Kaki Gorbachev says what
did you want me to say and an annoyed
Reagan turned to him and simply said you
should have said yes and we all know
what happened with history this is not a
time for games this is not a time to win
elections through media perfection
you know there was a whole Robert
Redford had a pretty cute little movie
back in the 70s the candidate the
candidate and what does he say after he
wins and he played TV what do we do now
what do we do now you know exactly is
America is that who you want you want
someone who's gonna be perfect and come
all the way up seriously and then Sadie
what do we do now I'll tell you what you
do now you have to if you take by the
way no one seems to understand I'll go
back to it real quick we'll talk about
this on China you know why it's so
significant on the one you know why
because it's not a floating currency on
International currency markets it gives
China the control of the value at any
given day and soon as you put that in
there
that you're giving them economic power
and when you go back they've said for a
long time well you know Russia would be
more stable economically if they had a
currency that was traded and respected
on the World Market you know what people
used to say they do it just has a
picture of George Washington on it
because it was the underground currency
if the underground currency of Russia
was a U.S dollar so we're going to put
somebody there that won't even allow
their currency to float with the
monetary markets and they're going to
determine the price of a gallon of gas
and and a cubic was it cubic feet of LNG
liquid natural gas really that's what
you want you want a perfect guy who's
gonna now win the election and say now
what do we do sorry I'm not on that page
you know I remember I was stationed over
in Italy with Airborne unit at the time
uh
yeah remember the bombing of the Disco
in in Germany uh that they tied back to
uh yes Bolivian terrorists and and what
did Reagan do I mean it was not any
debate what bam they bomb Libya and we
were like yeah that's that's cool I said
operation Rustic Canyon yeah it took us
five days to shoot a balloon down that's
what I'm saying but that's what you're
right and so so you're talking about
where we are finished its job just
floating floating panic
you know I just jot down here two quotes
from Alexander the Great number one he
says fortune favors the Bold so if
there's a message that I hear that you
want to get to Rhonda Sanders fortune
favors the bowl and the second thing
that Alexander said that I would not
fear an army of lions if they were led
by sheep but I would fear an army of
sheep in their favorite quote it's power
yeah it so powerful and America is an
army I mean it is an army of lions I
mean we want to we we want to get out
there and why hesitate let her rip stop
solving for Perfection go get a couple
black guys let's go let's brawl let this
is a real fight this is not a political
diplomatic strategy [__] [__]
fight I'm on a flight from L.A from
Burbank Airport to Vegas and I'm going
to Vegas because I got a business
meeting all of a sudden I look to my
right a guy named Bill O'Reilly's
sitting there I'm like [__] what are you
doing here so I'm taking a Burbank
flight why are you going there I'm doing
the Dennis Miller thing I don't know if
you guys remember him
since I got time with you I said so tell
me what happened here with Romney and
Obama he says look we called Romney to
come on the show because we felt
you know he needed to come and present
himself and we also called Obama because
we thought Obama was going to lose
and he says when I called Obama's Camp
about getting on the show Obama's camp
set the following he says Bill you're
wrong it's done
it's done Obama's winning he says why he
says because
Romney's Camp made a massive mistake
what was the mistake
Romney's Camp convinced Romney that he
had to go win the single woman salad
eating vote
and he screwed up instead of pushing
against Benghazi after the second debate
he was crushing him yes the moment he
flipped he lost who the hell is in the
ear of this man that could be a
president GoPro you're a fighter Ron
you're not a guy that sits on the
sidelines Let's Roll by the way this
message here will probably eliminate the
chance of sitting here sitting here
because they're definitely not not going
to have him come over here to this
podcast it's going to do it go to Megan
Kelly Nova go to PVD podcast show I'm
okay with that if you're gonna go out
there go roll this guy's a fighter he's
a tough guy you seem the way he handles
the media every time like when somebody
said no no no no we're not going to do
none like that's exactly what we need
today I'm not trying to be winning best
friends here I'm not trying to go and
say hey can we be best friends I don't
need to be best friends with you don't
need to be best friends with me but damn
it let's go see your fight cause you got
it you know you bring up a great point
because you remember those series of
debates between Romney and Obama the
first one was out in Colorado absolutely
just smoked about Obama was a a blah
blah blah blah blah and then you're
right someone got in his ear and you
know you can't do that you can't you got
to be president you don't want to see
his foot off the gas
the last debate was right here in South
Florida it was it Lynn University
remember it was foreign policy National
Security and that's when Obama came out
and said you know Russia is looking for
their uh the cold war strategy you know
you know Obama he just obliterated Robin
Rodney did not continue to go on the
offense and you had one of the worst
foreign policy National Security
Administration I mean Russia initially
went into Ukraine doing the Obama
Administration they came in Crimea and
they took the issue and what did Obama
say he said blankets and MREs
if he had just stood up and say you know
when I'm president I'm not sending
blankets and MREs
I'm sending bullets because I would not
see you know the incursion of a dictator
into a sovereign country do you remember
Obama sitting with Putin on an open mic
in illegal no Medvedev he was sitting
with me in Japan and he leans forward
and it's an open mic saying you know
he's apologizing and says I'll have more
flexibility after the election
absolutely tail Vladimir
and it's like what what
I thought that was just uh so I want to
go to a couple other stories but we can
talk about this for hours but I've got
two other stores I want to go to the
police shooting that took place the
tragic event videos were released I want
to get your thoughts as somebody who's a
vet uh you've been on all sides what's
your thoughts are on this you've also
been a school teacher so you know what
it is to be a teacher here in Plantation
so if you can play this clip and by the
way just so everybody knows YouTube came
out and says the graphic Nashville body
camera video can stay online despite
rules against violent content so they
want people to see this they're okay
with it so YouTube Just so you know
we're following your guide guidelines
Rob play this clip for everybody but
again brace for impact if you if you're
not good at watching things like this I
suggest you take a break from the clip
but we are going through it right now if
we can get our internet to work uh maybe
refresh it one more time Rob typically
when we do that this works and it's
decisive it's not gory it's decisive
yeah it actually makes our
um there you go go ahead
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
hit the stairs go downstairs go stairs
[Music]
ready
keep pushing
[Music]
shot spot shots fired shots fired move
right right right
push with lpbo push the lpbo go right
[Music]
reload
move move
watch out what's up
stop moving stop moving
I'm moving stop moving
suspect down suspect
uncomfortable if you see but
hey hold the air
first of all the disturbing video to
watch when you see this but this is this
this becomes realistically A playbook
for all the other units Nationwide to
look at and see are we training to be
able to do something like this so what's
your reaction when you see this well I
will tell you right now I've got some
dear friends in law enforcement down
here and I was talking with them last
night this is like you say it's going
all over the nation because this was
textbook take down 12 minutes from you
know them getting an emergency to the
neutralizing of the threat and I live in
Texas this is embarrassing for the folks
that were Uvalde because that's what
should have happened instead of allowing
someone to have free reign so hats off
to those two you know uh officers that
took control of the situation did not
sit around and wait for anyone to come
in and and say I'm the commander and I'm
going to tell you what to do no you move
to the sound of the guns that's what you
taught in the military and that's what
they should be doing and that's the
training but here's the real thing that
we need to come to understand
we're looking at a question that we
better answer real quick first and
foremost I would say that there's going
to be more security and protection at
the final four this weekend than are on
our schools so why don't we do what is
necessary in protecting our schools we
got you know Army ROTC NATO ROTC people
that are out there we've got you know
veterans that would be happy to go out
and provide security the fact that that
person was able to shoot out the the
entry point the gun the uh the windows
and nobody was there to confront them at
that point right there someone should
have been there on that campus to do
that so that's the first thing
but gender dysphoria
is a mental condition
and this individual suffer from gender
dysphoria and I'm not saying this myself
this is American Psychiatric Association
of saying this
we know that this person went to five
different gun stores and got seven
weapons
now each time they went to the gun store
they had to fill out a form 4473 which
is your background check form one of the
questions on 4473 asks you
about mental illness and depression
and we know that gender dysphoria has
two symptoms depression and anxiety
so a person that is suffering from a
mental condition should not be able to
go out and get weapons
now that's the thing that no one wants
to talk I know Randy Weingarten is
talking about taking away my gun as a
legal law but that that's not the end
number one better security for our
schools
because that shows where our priorities
are we'll secure a sports venue but
obviously we're not securing our schools
the second thing is we got to get
serious about the these background check
forms and in Texas and Sutherland
Springs the reason why that shooting
happened the Air Force forgot to upload
that Shooter's dishonorable discharge
and the fact that he was guilty of a
domestic abuse both questions on the
4473 that would have kept him from being
of guns and Uvalde Texas the shooter
there lived with his grandparents his
grandfather was a felon felons are not
supposed to number one ever be able to
possess Firearms or be in a residence
with Firearms when he put down the
address of his grandfather on that 4473
form the red flag should have popped up
that's where we got issues not coming in
and taking away your weapons take away
my weapons and disarming me which is
what all totalitarian leftists you know
regimes want to do because then you can
impart your will upon people but we got
to do better protecting our kids and we
got to put some teeth Behind these uh
these background check forms none of
this Universal background check stuff
but just let's make sure that the the
next system is able to do what it's
supposed to do
but people that suffer from a mental
condition should not be and I'll close
on this thing last week Friday or
Saturday whatever
the the
transgender Community there in Nashville
put out a national they wanted a day of
vengeance
you can Google it find it they wanted a
day of Vengeance one of the places that
they named was Nashville Tennessee
now the fact that someone asked mayor
Garland are you going to classify this
as a hate crime he didn't ask what this
is a hate crime wow
trans day of Vengeance right but because
less than a month ago uh Tennessee the
government came out and they were the
first they passed the legislators
absolutely protecting children saying
that we're not going to have these
gender mutilation you know surgery drag
queen events in public and puberty
blockers and hormonal therapies you know
for our children and this is what
happens in response you call out a day
Avengers no
so so you're trying to classify this as
a potential hate crime it's not a
potential hate crime there's only one
reason why this person was at that
school
I mean they're 28. why are you going to
go in and shoot nine-year-olds
so that and that's not what the media
wants to talk about
yeah why is there not more security
police officers military in front of
schools I mean to me this is insane like
we're watching this video right and the
whole time I'm watching it that he's
puffing and I'm thinking this is at an
elementary school this is what's
happening at a school
and my whole thing is how can we stop
this from happening in Denver Colorado
you just had a 17 to 18 year old just
shot two School administrators in Denver
Colorado this kid was known to be
violent but guess what the school board
there in Denver Colorado had just voted
for eliminate and removing all school
resource officers and so two School
administrators got shot right here at
Marjorie stallman Douglas everybody knew
about Nicholas Cruz Nicholas Cruz had 20
to 22 call outs to his residents okay it
was the Obama Administration Arne Duncan
who is the Secretary of Education Robert
Ronson down here they didn't want to
bring up any charges or whatever against
black and brown students because they
felt that that was racist
and the president and the presence of
security
um is uh hurtful to certain groups
because you're presupposing guilt so
we're going to pull back
um yeah you know we have systems out
there and we just need to use it you
brought up a couple good points and we
can debate these last couple points at
length but one of them is not debate the
systems exist if I if I have a drunk
driving condition a drunk driving
conviction in Maine and four months
later I go to Texas relocate and go to
get a Texas driver's license they're
going to tell me uh you're under
suspension you haven't finished out a
suspension we have a suspension here in
Maine you got two months to go here's
your government ID card with the red
stripe on it you can get your driver's
license when you're done it says and if
I try to bypass that and I go and
present my main driver's license and I
try to get a job driving a school bus or
a city bus the systems are all in there
the flag it same thing for um same thing
for Pilots so we have systems out there
that work very well State the state that
protect us and hold back so why don't we
have it why isn't it working well
exactly what you're talking about excuse
me your um you're you're buying this
firearm but this web this address just
came back this is an ineligible address
yeah and it says why well maybe they
won't know that okay your uncle's a
felon but you're at an ineligible
address dude and that's all you're
supposed to tell you yeah yeah you're
denied yeah you're denied that's it they
don't tell you what you're denied
so all of these things are happening
because there's a failure in the system
there's not a failure in you know any of
us here who go out and do the right
things we follow the laws bad people
don't follow laws did you see the
congressman getting emotional yesterday
saying ask them uh what Republicans will
do uh did you see that yesterday or no
okay I want to show you this clip if I
can find it uh Rob if you can look for
it this went viral yesterday is this the
big guy in the tense who he is coming
out and said ask him what are they going
to do about it what are they going to do
about ask Republicans about what they're
going to do about guns that's what you
need to ask him
um oh man it was it it was a very
emotional rally cry
uh about guns I wish I had the clip to
show it to you but this is an
opportunity people are using to blame
Republicans to not wanting to do
anything about this and not wanting to
have a conversation obviously you saw
here you you briefly commented about
what Randy winegarden said about the
fact that we need to do you know
confiscate guns similar to what
Australia and New Zealand did have the
courage to do what they did Nikki Haley
on the other hand says you know treating
shooting as only a gun issues the lazy
way out after the Nashville she's right
and then you know uh Tim Burchette says
Revival not Congress is needed after
Nashville school shooting so there's
three different perspectives here but
Democrats are saying this is Republicans
fault how come you're not doing anything
about it
what are the likelihood I asked this
question on Tuesday I'm curious you know
what your concern is with this what's
the likelihood of they're going to be
able to succeed
confiscate guns not not change maybe
getting stricter background checks and
all that kind of stuff how successful do
you think they can be to be able to take
guns away from them well the thing is
that is not about actually confiscating
the gun is trying to undermine the means
by which you can have the weapon so
we're going to go out and tax you for
every bullet that's in you know a case
of bullets uh and we're going to make it
so expensive that you have ammunition
that you just turn a handgun in just to
a to a hammer or we're going to come out
all of a sudden the ATF just recently
did this and we're going to say that you
know if you put an accessory on a quote
unquote you know semi-automatic pistol
now you have turned into a short barrel
rifle although the accessory doesn't
change anything about the the the
caliber the capability or the velocity
or muzzle velocity but now all of a
sudden uh it has to be regulated and oh
by the way if you don't turn it in and
tell us about it you are now a felon so
that's what they're trying to do is
they're trying to criminalize the
ownership of of weapons or they're
trying to undermine your ability to
effectively use a weapon uh and and it's
the same with these red flag laws uh
sounds good but there were a bunch of
red flags on Nicholas Cruz and no one
did anything about so now red flash can
become a political Hammer whereby you go
after someone and you don't know who
accused you and I believe it was in
October
2016-2017 a gentleman in Ferndale Gary
Wood Gary J Woods I believe his name
Ferndale Maryland he comes to the to the
door early in the morning like four or
five in the morning police are banging
on the door what if you banging on my
door four or five in the morning I'm
bringing my gun because I don't know who
you are he was shot and killed
the police were there to serve a red
flag uh uh notice on him but why are you
going to do that at four or five in the
morning
and to this day we don't know who the
police officer were that shot uh Gary
and we furthermore we don't know who
initiated the red flag but the guy's
dead Ferndale Maryland I forget the
county up there but
they will never be able to flat out say
we're taking away your guns first of all
that it's a it's a constitutional right
that you have but they're gonna that's
not at all something you're concerned
about uh I am concerned about them using
the the weaponization of the ATF and so
so now the agencies to try to undermine
your ability and criminalize your
ability to have certain fires so talking
about weaponization Jim Jordan just came
out and demands IRS explained
unannounced visit to Matt taibi's home
this is a National Review story Jim
Jordan sent a letter to treasurer
secretary Janet the Allen Iris
commissioner Daniel wurfel asking for an
explanation as to why federal agents
were sent to mataibi South on the same
day he appeared before the select
subcommittee on the weaponization of the
federal government which was chaired by
Jordan Tybee informed Jordan that the
IRS instructed him to contact the agency
four days later and he was told about
his 2018 and 2021 tax filings were
requested due to concerns over identity
theft Tybee shared his 2018 tax
submissions with the select committee
which showed no problems was registered
with the tax written for more than four
and a half years taibi shared a new
information revealing Twitter
censorships industrial complex which
showed the social media's platform
worked with federal agencies and ngos to
censor or downplay posts they found
objectionable now objectionable how much
it is is just ironic coincidental how
much of this we think was intentional
it's totally intentional everything that
we have happening in this government
right now is purposeful and intentional
uh that's my big concern is the
censorship issue that's my big concern
about going after people and trying to
instill that fear and weaponizing
federal government agencies uh they can
do it better if if you're disarmed but
why don't you just send an email
I mean ask a guy about you know whatever
this identity issue is why are you
showing up at his house the day that
he's in Washington DC you're sending a
message I mean that's what the mafia
does okay that's what gangs do to send a
message that's what the clan used to do
burning crosses you know in the front
yard so this government that we have
right now Patrick this is the thing that
scares me the most it reminds me of the
East German Stasi police
where all of a sudden if you're a
pro-life activist an advocate you end up
in jail if you're Jane's Revenge that is
going out and firebombing you know
pro-life pregnancy centers and attacking
churches and vandalizing churches
nothing happens to you
if you're just a person that's walking
through the capitol on January 6 you're
a felon you're in jail if you're antifa
that shows up and you shoot at police
officers and burn down government
buildings and everything nothing happens
to you as a matter of fact we're going
to raise money to help you to make the
bail
so there's a two-tier system of justice
that is going on here and again it comes
back that's what the left does to its
opposition
the left does not want opposition they
want to instill you talk about fear they
want to instill fear in you that says if
you stand up to us we're going to get
you 87 000 new IRS agents what do you
think that means there'll be a lot more
people coming around and paying visits
to folks and Matt taibi is no
conservative he's no magic guy
whatsoever which is actually more
libertarian actually left-leaning
liberal they made in one now yeah of
course that's what's going to happen
yeah yeah and by the way we need more
investigative journalists so shout out
to mate before doing the hard work that
he does let let's talk about a place
that maybe would need to bring Matt
tybin to train them New York Times turns
on fauci essay slams reaction during
covet this story just came out uh let me
go to a Daily Mail story
page 14 here we go so the New York Times
published an opinion piece criticizing
Dr Anthony Thatcher's approach to
information sharing the okova 19
pandemic the article primarily focused
on fauci's initial reaction with ef
rotation of the covid lab League Theory
and his association with the British
zoologist Peter daisak the author Megan
stack wrote that fauci and zazak could
have qualified their statement to expose
Americans to more of the full picture
regarding the Wuhan Institute of
virology bad virus research but they did
not stack also condemned fauci for
initially lying about the effectiveness
of masks and frequently moving the goal
post on when it would be safe to live
lockdowns measures this is like a this
is more of a Babylon Beast story than a
New York Times stack argued that fauci's
dishonesty and promotional
disinformation contributed to the
problem of censorship and are you in
suppression of certain ideas she
concluded that attempting to clean up
this information by suppressing this
course creates its own dangers and can
lead to a society where nobody really
believes anything no [__] Sherlock so
Alan thoughts on the story you know you
we had this thing in in aerosol units
called cut sling load you know what I'm
talking about they just cut sling load
on Fouche Fouch is done uh and they're
going to distance themselves and and put
sling load that means that you're like
what they did to formal they're about to
do to Fouch yeah you know you come in
with a helicopter and you can pick up
like a Humvee or anything with the sling
attach it well when you're ready to drop
it you cut sling load and that's what
they've done meaning the helicopter
cannot carry the helicopter yeah just
cut it we're gonna just cut and bait
they're moving on but is it a little
ironic this is after the fact he's
already retired he's done he's the
highest paid employee in the government
they they they are getting ready for
2024. why do you think Governor Gretchen
Whitmer all of a sudden comes out and
says you know Michigan yeah I you know I
probably went too far whoops oops I'm
sorry if I ruin your business or I ruin
your life why they're getting ready to
set themselves up for 2024. they don't
want this to be a conversation because
they know that the American people have
STM short-term memory and so fauci's
going to get hit with a lot of class
action lawsuits it's coming and so New
York Times and everybody they're
separating themselves they don't want
anybody to come back and say that the
New York Times were part of this they
don't want to be part of a lawsuit
saying that they promote so you're
basically saying they're putting hit
pieces out there saying hey we did our
part it might have been three years too
late however we did write some hit
pieces we call that the Pontius Pilate
I'm washing my hands yeah uh so if I'm
fouchy I'm I should be worried because
now I'm I'm being told I'm on my own
they've they've cut bait on me
well I'm sure a lot of people are
sympathizing for this happening to fauci
uh as well as the sympathy they have for
a World Health Organization which
recently came out and said
w-h-o World Health Organization says
healthy kids and teens don't need
coveted vaccinations
I'm telling you the World Health
Organization has updated its guidance on
covid-19 vaccines recommending that
healthy children adolescents may not
need to receive the Shah The Who
considers vaccinating healthy young
people to be a low priority as a public
health impact this you are so dark World
Health is much lower than that of
traditional essential vaccine vaccines
for children's like measles measles and
polio who also called for Urgent efforts
to catch up on routine vaccinations
missing during the pandemic and warrant
of a rising vaccine preventable diseases
like measles the CDC reported a high
record high of almost 40 million
children missing
their measles vaccines in 2021
misinformation why do you think I wonder
why you're missing 40 million
misinformation linked to coveted
vaccines has also led to parents
rejecting normal childhood shots despite
immunizations being the most effective
way to protect children from measles
this is a Daily Mail story you know it's
funny it's almost like we played a
record and then we stopped and then we
start playing a record backwards it's
all changed because who was like uh we
think it's now acceptable for 16 year
olds up we think it's now acceptable for
12 year olds actually we think that the
states that will mandate it if their
Governors are smart we can go to 10 year
olds remember that we kept going down uh
we think eight-year-olds would be fine
we kept going down now the who said no I
don't think any of the 8 10 12 16s or
18s it's like we're going backwards they
they don't need it remember that we went
down the ages now we go back up the ages
there's no legitimacy here truth is is
powerful and they are now understanding
that how the hoodwink linked not just
the United States American entire world
is is coming to fruition it's coming
back against them and of course why
would you trust the who I mean China
owns the who you know who this favors
one guy this only favors one guy yeah it
favors the guy that is campaign for 2024
should be I told you so that's one guy
and he's going to come out one by one he
just needs to have one by one stories Uh
Russian uh uh uh collusion number one uh
covet vaccine for kids number two uh
shutting down number three School Number
Four you know all of these things he
just needs to go one by one by one story
and both him and the scientists can use
that I Told You So campaign because the
scientists can say I told you what I did
in the State of Florida Trump can do the
other side the left has to apologize did
you see how this Biden two days ago said
Republicans are the reason behind the
fentanyl issue because they're not
taking a border seriously did you see
that did you see that a couple days ago
who's gonna fall for that
to say something like that I mean this
is the part where you have to be so
you're willing to go to such levels to
Gaslight people you're officially
thinking the voters are dumb that's what
you think well they they believe in the
and then and hopefully this won't get
you in trouble down here but the
minister of propaganda for the Germans
Goebbels who said if you repeat a lot
often enough eventually people will take
it for the truth and and that's what
they're going to continue to do look
you just got to go down to the Border
you just gotta understand this and look
at the numbers this is all because of
one single person one single
Administration purposeful and
intentional the fact that we have close
to two million people in the United
States of America come across that
border we have no idea where they are
that's scary and again coming back to
having someone that is strong all of
those folks that got released out of
prison uh in Afghanistan they want some
payback and the cartels will help
anybody get into the United States of
America as long as they pay them the
money and something eventually is going
to go Kaboom in the United States of
America because there are people that
have come across they don't mean us good
last story before we wrap up Tom I want
to go to you with this one this is an
FTX story FTX founder Sam bankman free
charged with bribing Chinese officials
this is a Wall Street Journal
story he has been accused of prosecutors
of conspiring to bribe Chinese
government officials to Reign access to
over billion dollars in Frozen
cryptocurrency which violated the U.S
anti-corruption law bankmen freed
authorized the payment of at least 40
million dollars in cryptocurrency to one
or more of Chinese government officials
after months of failed attempts to
regain control of the accounts according
to the indictment Bank
bankman freed directed Alameda employees
to pay the bribe in the authorized an
additional payment of 10 tens of
millions of dollars to complete the
bribe Alameda use the unfrozen crypto to
fund additional trades as bankman freed
uh Freed's Direction Tom
is anybody now surprised how all of
those Democrat congressmen and senators
were dead silent when this guy got
arrested and when this thing went down
do you remember the pictures of him
walking across the floor of Congress and
Maxine Waters standing up on a chair or
a little dice there and blowing him
kisses literally blowing him kisses if
that's not scary enough pull that up
and and you look at what's going on and
then they were all silent and this this
guy was this guy was a was a bribery
machine this was a Ponzi scheme and that
he had already he knew what was going on
and he was covering himself with
donations and bribes I don't know why
anybody is surprised and so why is
everybody surprised that the only guy
that was interrupted at the microphone
was the prosecutor on this none of the
politicians have you notice how quiet
they were
it's because I I I I need to be on
vacation
and that's Maxine Waters when she was
the chairperson chairman of the house
chairman of the house Financial Services
committee that tells you everything who
is the number one contributor to the
Democrat Party after George Soros it
wasn't ftex right it tells you a lot Tim
Beckman free oh yeah yeah anyway it's
great show today we cover a lot of
stories Alan thank you so much for
coming out I appreciate your service
truly to come back down here to home and
I want everyone to know how special it
was to have been a member of Congress
representing this District right where
you are sitting uh that that means a lot
and that's a testimony to the
exceptionalism this country that the kid
can come from where I came from and rise
up to be a member of the United States
born in a blacks only Hospital Atlanta
Georgia in 1961 crazy where we've come
in this country and think about this the
year that I was born blacks could not go
on Fort Lauderdale Beach
but 50 years later I'm sworn in it as
the member of Congress that represents
great country wow you gotta love that
that's a great story so what what
projects are you working on anything
you're working on for the audience yeah
I'm the executive director of the
American constitutional rights Union uh
dacru.org it's a 27 year old
organization it's kind of meant to be
the counterbalance to the ACLU uh a lot
of things we work on our first amendment
Second Amendment uh issues as well as
election Integrity issues I have my own
podcast so tune in guys the steadfast
and loyal if uh you'd like and uh one of
the things I just did was a monologue on
the uh the shooting there in Nashville
and we just interviewed uh Sebastian
Gorka and also uh Dinesh D'Souza uh on
Tuesday before I flew down here so uh
that's it I love it we're going to put
the link to your podcast as well as the
website here Rob so the audience can go
find it once again thanks for coming out
this was fantastic appreciate you thank
you sir thank you take care guys bye-bye